and we're going to start with the bronze
medal and the this year it goes to a
film from a school whose animation work
has also been rewarded many times in the
past these awards it was made at the
ringling college of art design by Abner
Geller and Stevie Lewis let's hear it
for them although don't come up yet
you're going to show your movie actually
once again they cleverly made a movie
short enough that we could actually show
it as an entirely right here it's called
defective detective and its lead
character you'll enjoy this I've seen it
and he gives sort of Inspector Clouseau
a run for his money thank you very much
for coming and seeing us all tonight
it's been such a great honor again being
in this whole week of events so with all
these other great filmmakers I mean so
talented I've never seen such a great
great community of students so we wanted
to start off by thanking our composer
who did a wonderful job Raphael and
really truly an honor to work with
overseas and our sound designer Clement
who also did a wonderful job with the
sounds keeping it cartoony and fun so
I'd like to thank my mom who has been
such a great support with through all
this I can't believe that she put up
with me sometimes but um thank you so
much and to my family for their
wonderful support and my boyfriend Mike
and so we got again really thank you so
much for the Academy for having us here
it's a huge honor for four years ago
when I moved from Israel to Florida I
could not imagine that I'll ever be
standing in a place like this I like to
thank all the faculty at Ringling
College of Art in design and Oliver
amazing friends to spend many many
nights with us working on their films we
couldn't done it without em especially
our instructors have there and Billy
merritt who wasn't in real inspiration
every day to my best friend Lee ronto
passes here with
me today who's been my older brother
throughout all those years and through
this process Layla for your patience and
for my family my parents and my sister
who's been a huge support through all
these years and keep encouraging me to
do what I love thank you so much